uh I'm Peter from vizu so great to have
you
here
and um yeah
Zachary yeah and I'm I'm Zachary here uh
from Snowflake working on the streamlet
team very excited to have you here
today absolutely and uh so actually this
is something we've done only once before
together with Zachary at Pilot in New
York roughly a month ago which was a
like a real live session so this is the
first time we do it virtually and we've
come up with some new ideas on how we
should sorry Zachary are you talking
because you're
muted Okay so we've we've come up with
some ideas on how to get you involved
and and we would want you to be able to
build uh your own uh first apps in
streamlit with an IPI visu chart in it
that's interactive due to uh uh the
using the streamlit interactive controls
and uh but we we haven't done it before
so you can expect things to be a little
like you know complicated at certain
points but we we're here to help you and
figure it out so whenever you have any
questions or any issues just uh feel
free to to U ask questions or just pop
in and and uh yeah let's see let's see
how it goes uh I'm not sure how many of
you have been in part of the the talk
that I gave earlier today uh maybe the
the intro bit from the visu side will be
just a rerun for you then but uh
obviously I would want to we would want
to get everybody on the same page so I
will I mean in the initial visu intro
part uh you will see some things that
you've already saw maybe three hours ago
but uh yeah it's uh never I mean
animated charts always look nice so I
hope you'll still enjoy it so without
further Ado let me show you uh the
visual intro and then I'll give the
floor to Zachary to give you the intro
of streamlit and then we'll work towards
uh deep diving into some specific
examples on how to use the two things
together so I'm just going to share my
screen right
now
um and
uh hopefully you can see it it should be
coming up
um yep there you
go so first of all let me give you a
quick example of what is possible uh
using streamlit and and IP visu together
so this is a streamlit app you can
recognize it from the different controls
this is this is uh like one app that
actually has a a lot of different pages
now we're focusing on this one where you
see an IP Vis chart in the center it
shows uh uh Revenue
uh of different music formats in the US
over the years and the and the user of
the app can uh just fiddle with these
interactive controls like extending or
changing the time frame uh changing the
the value being shown to to have the
revenue inflation adjusted uh switching
it over I hope the animations go through
the the screen sharing um switching it
over to to show the volume uh
aggregating the the values not by year
but rather
by format so show the total values um
you can add more formats either with
these buttons or uh or using this uh
this selection field here uh you can uh
or the user can sort it by value and so
basically uh user can generate a lot of
different views of the same data set uh
whatever they prefer uh using the stream
L controls and also in the background
there is an animated story being created
so if I download it uh this is is like
an early implementation of this feature
then an HTML file is getting downloaded
to my uh computer and if I open it up uh
I will see uh um basically every step
that I did so like extending the time
frame uh to the right and then uh adding
some years uh like removing some years
from the left side changing it to
inflation adjusted and so on and so
these are all
these these been all um saved as as
slides in an interactive presentation
that you can um go through with these
buttons beneath the chart or uh and and
you can even seek the animation so like
uh really uh see through uh very uh
neatly uh what happened beneath uh like
between one stage to another uh so it's
it's it's like really super uh intuitive
at least we hope and basically you
create or the user created an an
animated file that someone can just uh
send in a in an email to to somebody
else and then you know basically created
this animation for themselves and so uh
the way it works is it use is like from
the visu side uh is that we built sorry
for the background noise I have a
two-year-old back home who's super
enthusiastic since it's uh um centa
coming to came today so we basically
have a gener charting engine that uh can
create a lot of different charts and can
seamlessly animate between them uh
that's the the core of everything we do
uh this this super flexible chart
animation engine and uh the way the
reason for doing this is that we're
working towards this vision of building
a GUI for data that would enable uh
basic business users so not only experts
like you to explore their data visually
to build these sort of animated stories
that you just saw using it on reports
and dashboards such as the ones that
we're about to build or use it even for
for casting and planning uh we initially
focused on storytelling and everything
we've done so far is basically those are
open source uh tools that they're
available for you for free uh the reason
why we focus so much on animation is
that we think it helps a lot in
understanding especially for nonexperts
uh the connection between different
views of the same data set so if I show
you these four charts it might not be
obvious what's the connection between
them but if I connect them using
animation then you know no further
explanation is necessary and and it's
easy for people to understand uh
the the relationship between these two
uh so to just to give you a couple of
easy examples like drilling down to show
components of a composite index and the
relationship between them is is very
intuitive using animation uh or uh also
to
uh show the the the parts in a in a
stack chart and and show if like one
component in this case the population of
the forecasting population of Europe
goes against the global Trend um you can
also just switch between uh Aggregate
and and values and and distribution over
time just like we did with the music
data um you can uh show change over time
using uh animation and time as a as a
additional menion compared to static
charts uh and U and you can even turn
one chart into a whole story just by
adding a new feature and then zooming in
to separate parts this case it's the
number of smartphones different
companies produced and the and the
revenue that uh that that they generated
selling these phones and and obviously
there are like these leagues of
companies
and and due to the animation you get
this sense of magnitude and and
understand uh the Dynamics of this
Market a little better so uh our our
technology is built on a C++ core engine
that we used in house uh and then we
released our in our first open source
tool at JavaScript charting Library back
in uh 2021 and the first tools for
python users and data scientists for
python programmers and data scientists
um came out
uh uh March 2022 uh which we added an
extension mention to back in July 2022
that while which you people can create
these uh these animated data stories
that you can actually build present and
share uh from a computational notebook
such as Jupiter notebook and others and
uh we have a ton of Integrations uh for
different notebooks and and other types
of tools and obviously today we're going
to focus on the streamate integration
which is I think the most uh uh enhanced
and and uh that's due to Zachary's work
who actually built this integration
between these two tools uh so yeah I
mean uh I'm going to show you just one
example how um how ipiv visu Works uh
you can follow along easily if you go to
this link that's shown now on the screen
um or you can use the QR code as well
um and uh if you do that so it's bit.
lvu hyen
pyata global
you will end up at this uh repo folder
uh so in visu workshops a separate repo
folder for Pata Global and there are a
lot of so useful links in the readme uh
the apps that are that we're going to
use and also the slides from my side and
from Zachary so uh even after the
tutorial you would have the opportunity
to just you know um take an look at uh
and and reuse every material that we
prepar for you and within the notebooks
folder you see a couple of example
notebooks uh that that uh introduce you
to the concept and the syntax and the
logic of of IPI visu
um so uh if you so just as a quick intro
to the iPad visu logic we have one
method within the package that you can
actually install via pip or cond uh
that's called the animate method and if
you call it once you'll get to a static
chart and if you call it once again
again then you'll get to then it will
animate to a second chart obviously the
animation bit is taking care of our
engine so we don't have to worry about
that part uh you add the data that you
want to visualize the configuration of
the chart and and you can set the look
and feel of your chart with the style
object and you also have the opportunity
to fle with the animation options but we
try to build everything in a way that it
works out of box nicely but like for
example when you build a racing bar
chart that I just showed you you might
want to reduce the any animation time
the duration of the animation between
slides it's yeah you you just write
duration equals 0.1 and then it will be
it's much quicker so for this first
example we're you going to use the
Titanic data set you can see the data
here on the right side we just added a
account column and uh we're working uh
together with pandas uh you can just uh
import these objects from IP visu you uh
read the data frame using pandas like uh
the csv2 a data frame you create an
empty data object and by calling the
adddf method of the data object you you
just add the data frame to it so it's
easy as that and then here we create an
empty chart where we set the width and
the height and we just add the data to
it so basically we create an empty chart
the data is already there but we haven't
set up anything yet and this is the
first time where we actually create uh
the chart uh using the config object
within the animate method uh and it will
create a bar chart with the count on the
xaxis and the sex of the passengers on
the y-axis and uh and and we also have
the the label Channel and if I add the
count there too then the numbers also
appear next to the the the the bars and
uh as you can see uh iPad Vis
automatically aggregated summed up the
count values here so uh you can use
different aggregation Logics like mean
or c
uh but yeah it's it's the the out of box
or the default value is to sum up the
values and so in the next phase I'm just
going to call the animate method once
again and add the survived category to
the xais and also to the color channel
uh and this way we create and as you can
see the transition was obviously
animated a stacked bar chart where the
people who died in the crash are colored
differently than those who survived
again the numbers are automatically agre
at and the labels are being
repositioned uh in order to fit the the
Stacked bar chart rather than the simple
one that we saw in the previous cell and
so now we have a ton of other options
that I'm going to just very quickly
showcase so first of all let's see just
again a simple example and I'll remove
the comments that I'm going to add right
now it is to that we remove the survive
category from the x-axis you see it's
only the count remains there and we add
it to the Y AIS and this is a um
transformation where we basically group
uh the elements uh on the y- axis and
again it turn it it happens in an
animated fashion we have also the
geometry parameter and instead of
rectangles the data can be represented
by circles if we do that we can also add
them uh the the count value on the size
uh then then these circles will have
different sizes and we can actually
change the coordinate system
uh to Polar uh to end up in a chart that
doesn't make sense anymore uh and and
that that can happen like you know in a
in a generic charting tool you can build
charts that that no one understands
but obviously this is not something you
want to do but I just wanted to like
give you a better understanding of how
things work here you can also style the
chart so for example I'm changing the
color pette here by Chang in the plot
Mark poot uh parameter and adding just a
list of colors and if I rerun the cell
then the markers would have better
suiting colors here and I can also just
filter the data like this and and only
the it means that only those traveling
on first class uh will remain on the
chart uh and again everything happens in
an animated fashion so this is the first
very basic introduction of IPI visu that
I wanted to give give you and now I'm
going to uh give the floor to um to
Zachary uh so that he can give you an
intro of how stream
works thanks Peter all right I'm so I'm
gonna um I'm gonna give a a fairly a
fairly uh quick intro to streamlet and
and give kind of a context of how um
streamlet fits with vizu and and um so I
assume some of you have probably used
stream some of you have heard of it some
of you haven't yet so hopefully this
will be this will be helpful um for a
range of
people um let me start here so uh my
name is Zachary Blackwood I work at
snowflake we I was part of the part of
the streamlet we were acquired by
snowflake uh a couple years ago and I'm
work on data engineering there and part
of my work part of my uh data
engineering work the best part is I get
to build lots of stream blood apps um
so streamlet is a tool to connect data
to the rest of the company
so it is uh it is specifically built it
is specifically designed so that you can
take uh the data that you have that you
want to show to somebody and produce
very very quickly um a data app out of
it that you can share with other people
that they can explore that they can use
um um people who who don't want to look
at the raw data who don't want to who
don't want to see just a notebook where
you did all your work but they actually
want to see the end result um and the
way you use stream is it's just you just
write a python script and you write a
python script and it produces when it
when you run it it produces a web app
and it's an interactive web app it can
have all kinds of things in it for
example here you see some filters and
some tables and some charting um and it
really is it's quite straightforward to
get started with works with a lot of
different
libraries and we've built in a we've
added a lot of different um widgets so
here's here's a few of them um you have
you know sliders and you here you have
an example of an Al a chart and a file
uploader and a Color Picker and a date
picker and all those all those kinds of
things that you would
expect
um you can use it with quite a few
different libraries so here are just a
few but essentially if if you have a if
you have a python Library um You
probably can can use it with your stream
but app and
um and uh it's very it's very likely it
has a first-party integration with streo
so that you can even see the output of
it um right away so you can take your
stream you can take your python script
that originally just ch punched some
code and maybe produce a chart and turn
it into a full interactive app using
your favorite
libraries um so the three core
principles of stream is number one you
Embrace python scripting you treat vets
as variables and you reuse data and
computation so I'll get explained what
that means just a minute um one of the
things that I really like about python
is it's really easy to just write a
script and run it and have it do
something I don't need to necessarily
make a complicated thing with lots of
different files and and and abstractions
and classes and objects I can just write
a script that runs from top to bottom
and that's that's very much what
streamlet Embraces so so here you see
example where you have a couple
streamlet commands sd. write and then
some p a panda command and then another
st. line chart and that's it and you
don't have to you don't have to abstract
it any any more than that you can just
um you can just write out that what you
wanted to do and it runs from top to
bottom um when you have something like a
slider um you you just write x equals
st.
slider and then for the rest of the app
whenever X gets used whenever the slider
gets updated the value of x changes and
I don't have to think um for much of the
time I I really don't need to think
about call backs and what's actually
happening behind the scenes so that when
this Updates this changes and when this
Updates this changes the the vast
majority of the time I can just say I'm
going to write the value X set it equal
to a a widget and I'm going to use that
for the rest of the
app um another another really important
piece is excuse me um uh is that you
want to be able to much of the time you
want to just run the whole script
sometimes there are certain things that
are slow there are certain things you
really only want to run once like create
a database connection or uh uh grab some
data from a URL or from a or from your
database and so we have built-in caching
um Primitives so that you can you can
cach those results so you don't have to
run them every time so in general
interactions to your script don't cause
those to rerun
unnecessarily um the thing about stream
bu apps is they're meant to be
interactive they're designed to be
things they're designed to be played
with they're designed to be they're
designed to be something that can you
can allow you to explore which is why it
works really well with something like
like
vizu um so here's a really minimal
example um this does nothing so far it
just loads some data saves into variable
data and it does cache it so that every
time you run it once you've run it once
um it doesn't if you want that to expire
you can do that as well but for now it
just grabs some data saves it in a
variable um now we have a widget that
we're adding a multi- select widget we
have three different countries and and
we saved that value into the value of
countes so whatever you set here
whatever if you add a new thing or or x
x one of those out the value is is set
in countries and now we have doing some
typical pandas
filtering um and some SD WR commands and
we've transformed this data slightly um
and notice that we're we're using the
output of the country's widget to filter
our data so in this in this case we're
showing all three but if you if you
change the multi- select it would show
one it would show different ones and now
we're making a um an aler chart um just
plotting that data um and there you go
there's the full app top to bottom um
and it's interactive and you can change
what countries they're showing of course
you get add other things like filtering
by year and things like that um once you
have the
basics uh there's there's lot ways you
can take it um people you know this it's
particularly focused around data data
apps so people build all kinds of things
um
from um from you know an app that'll you
know propo supposedly tell your fortune
to a you know a full-on Dungeon Crawler
game really not what streamland is
designed for but people go crazy with
these things um so you can have
multi-page apps for example where like
the examples will show you where each
each you have these tabs on the side and
you can switch between different pages
um of course very popular these days
people want to have chat interactions
they want to interact with llms so we
have these native chat components um
that allow you to not just output text
but output things like like charts and
things like
that um and there's lots of Integrations
with things like um with lots of
different llm
Tools around that and people are people
it's been fun to watch what all people
have build what all people have built
using these different
models um there's a great Forum people
spend a lot of time there I spend a lot
of time there answering questions and uh
there's great documentation so if you're
if you're wanting to get started that's
a great place to go um there's a gallery
that'll show you all the some kinds of
different apps that people make and
again it's a it's a wide variety of
things that people are
building um other thing that stream has
for you is it's a place to host your
apps for free so so it's called
Community cloud and you can take your
your app that's in a GitHub repo and
with a few clicks you can have it hosted
in place you can share with the world um
but if you want to just get started
locally you pip install stream and run
the stream
hello I wanted to also talk very briefly
about components because that's really
what we're here today is talking about
the the component that allows you to
interact with streamlet and vizu
together so if you have a streamlet app
there's a lot of things that are
natively supported but SU there's
there's something that a python Library
does or JavaScript library does and you
want to be able to use that in your
streamlet app right kind of natively
embedded in streamlet so sometimes you
can just use it directly again if it's
just if it's um in a lot of cases you
can just use it as is um it doesn't
always work though particularly with
JavaScript based libraries um you can't
always use those directly in your stream
blood app so you can you can make a
component so component is a way to take
to take some python code or some
JavaScript code and turn it into
reusable essentially you can make your
own widget so we have various widgets
and you can make your own widget and
publish it as a component so here's some
examples um of components that people
people have made to do lots of different
things um here's a blog post and and
this this slide is linked in the the
bitly link so if you want to if you want
to read that blog post about making a
component you can do that um so with
stream vizu um there's already an
excellent JavaScript library underneath
and there's already a python wrapper to
embed it in a notebook and so I saw this
and thought what if we could hijack that
and reuse that in fact I've already done
this with with a a library called folium
so I knew it was possible it's a great
library for for doing uh for making for
making maps and geo geo geospatial um
visualizations so I had already done
this with with fium and I thought what
if we could do it with vizu and so
that's what stream vizu is so it's a way
to have a streamlet app with a visual
animation embedded and you can get
things out of that you can interact with
it you can change it and you can get
data um you can get data out of
that um we'll have more time for for
questions and comments but I um we'll
I'll I'll pass it on back to to Peter
for
now thanks Zachary so I'm pretty sure
your head is buzzing already there's
been so much content shown to you in
such a short period of time uh in the
next uh section we're going to show you
some streamlet apps that we specifically
built for you uh to help you learn IPI
visu without having to learn uh the the
the syntax and the logic so we want to
make it so much easier for you to get
started and then we'll show you a couple
of examples uh together with the python
code behind so so like an iivy chart
within streamlet and also the code for
it so you get the sense of how these two
things can work together and then um
Zachary built a great app uh that could
help you get started also we we wanted
to simplify everything uh make it easy
for you to take your first steps but as
I said this is the first occasion that
we do this and as such we would want to
get your feedback at the very end so I
just want to give you the early warning
sign that I will ask you to fill a form
towards the end of this session actually
I think towards the end of the frontal
part of the session and then we will
have some time for individual work where
we would give you all the resources for
to get started and then you can actually
build your first IPI visu apps and uh
like stream Lo apps with IPI visu in it
and we'll be here to to to see you
through the the whole process so that's
that's what we have in mind so um
let me uh hi alen thanks for for
stopping by um
so let me share once again my screen and
show you an app that we built together
with Zachary and with David from the
visu team which is called the visu
Builder you can actually go and check it
out right away so it's vizu hyen Builder
the streem L app now what it does it you
can upload your data to it using this
control here for for the sake of this
presentation I will just use the sample
data by switching on this uh this little
switcher here uh it shows you what kind
of what series are there within the data
and whether IP visu thinks it's a
category or a value in terms of values
like in terms of the year which only
contains numbers it can happen that IP
visu thinks that it's a value where it
should be a category so we list all the
values or the assumed values here for
you and basically with this drop down
you can change the the the data type for
that data series that column of the data
frame and um so basically at step three
comes the important or the interesting
bit where you basically just select some
categories and values from your data
frame Let's uh start with I don't know
year and quarter and let's add the the
item sold uh here and uh the aggregation
logic whether it's sum or mean or Max we
we're going to stick to sum and uh you
can actually add everything that you
selected on the label so I'm just going
to use item sold which will make some of
the charts crowded but whatever and then
I just hit create charts and what
happens next and uh brace yourself it's
not going to be very fast because there
are a lot of things happening in the
background uh is that and and you can
actually expect some error messages to
appear these which don't seem to show up
right now but don't worry oh yeah this
one you you don't have to worry about
that too it just means that there are a
lot of things happening in the
background but basically after some time
uh a list of charts visu charts appear
here and it basically gives you all the
different combinations of the two
categories so the year quarter and the
value the item sold and all the
different charts that are we think would
make sense to build with viu and you
have them all here right within a single
app what you can do with these charts is
basically you can you can uh check out
the code that it took uh for us to to
create this chart uh together with the
styling and you can just uh copy and
paste it either by just clicking here or
you know selecting everything and then
you can put it to your own uh streamlet
app and reuse it there that's what we're
going to you do later on or you can just
uh put it in a notebook and reuse it
over there you have to change is the
reference to the data file but uh with
the sample app you don't even have to
deal with that because we set up
everything that way the other thing you
can do here is just add these charts to
a story uh basically just by and then
again it slows down a bit because things
happening in the background uh so you
can just uh click on some of these
charts and and add them to a story uh
each time something is happening in the
background and what actually does happen
we are going to reveal that
right away so basically there is an iPad
visit story being
created um right beneath the
charts um here we go so here's the story
it's going to appear the last one right
away so it has already four slides
because I clicked on four the add to
charts uh add chart to story button on
four of the slides and and it basically
contains all of these charts that I
clicked on and you have again the
automated animated transitions beneath
the slides that you added there and this
one might not look that good but you
know we we we we are uh early stage in
that regard uh you can delete the last
slide you can download the story
similarly to the first example that I
showed you so as a separate HTML file
and you can also just check out the code
for the whole story basically you one
slide is is is uh again contains
everything thing that that can be seen
on the chart it's a little bit more
verbos because it's a generic thing so a
lot of default things are being
specifically explicitly Set uh but it's
we think it's the easiest way to get
started with visu without having to
understand this whole abstract syntax of
adding different data series to to to
xes and channels so U we hope that uh
that this will help you get started with
visu and again you can copy and paste
this code to your notebook to rearrange
the slides to change the styling to add
new slides and whatever you prefer you
can also just you know change the
settings around here so for example um
filter the data frame on well let's say
the coder meaning that again uh
dynamically another streamlit uh control
appears and I'm going to just remove uh
Q3 for the sake of this uh presentation
update the charts and then what happens
on all of the charts is that uh
the or yeah I think it should be and
maybe I haven't clicked on it
properly so that all the markers that
belong to Q3 will just be removed from
these chart so as you can see they the
yellow bits vanished from every chart
and if you you know add the the newly
updated uh charts to your story you can
have these really neat
transitions uh of uh something being
filtered out uh so you can zoom on
specific bits I really like this uh this
zooming effect of the filter it's
important to understand that in an
animated charting fashion filtering
equals to zooming uh to certain parts so
this this was one this is one of the
apps that that we wanted to show you and
and would expect for you to use it and
and to jump start your learning
experience the other one is you can find
it at the intro to visu streamlet app
and these are uh some examples from
basic to as you can see this is a
multi-page app it has eight pages with
different first simple and then more
complex examples of uh of IPI visu uh of
streamlet apps in IPI visu so let me
just show you the code for for this app
right beneath the app itself uh we're
importing pandas and streamlet here and
we don't uh use IP visu but rather
streamlet visu the component that Zach
built but we import the same thing so
config data and style and instead of
chart we have a visu chart object but
it's basically the same as the chart in
IPI visu and we create first an empty
chart uh and then we we create a very
simple data frame with one categorical
and one numerical series so XY 7123 we
create once again an empty data object
we add the data frame to the data object
and we we add that um data object uh to
the chart with the animate method and uh
basically it's just we use uh to the
animate method two times this is the
initial
configuration where the C category the
XY Z is on the
xaxis
and uh and instead of of a horizontal
sorry a vertical bar chart or column
chart we get to a proper bar chart like
this and then if I remove uh this
checkbox then we get back to uh the
column chart and uh this part uh it's uh
to showcase the B directionality of the
thing uh meaning that if I click on any
of the charts uh then uh the value of
the click bar is being shown here U it
enables uh some really neat interactive
features which I'm going to show you
just one example of before giving the
floor back to Zachary so another example
would be and we would expect you to
build simple apps like this one for the
sake of the uh like this this tutorial
is uh when we have a SL slider again
it's the music Revenue data and if I
change the slider we show the DF shows
the the data for that year uh that
specific year and uh so I talked a
little bit about the the zooming
bit so again it's basically just
utilizing the
filtering uh part of of IPI vizu uh we
once again import everything we need we
read the CSV file now so but it's
basically just a standard this thing and
then we create the chart uh and but this
is where we build we add the slider a
streamlit slider uh that reads its value
its set value to the variable called
year we set the main and ax value and
the default value and then uh we have a
single animate method here where the
data the filter bit is set in a way that
the the record so the year uh value of
the data frame records should equal to
the year set here and then uh we just
create a group bar chart here we use the
config bit a little bit differently we
have these presets where uh the revenues
in the x-axis the format on the y-axis
it's grouped by format so that all of
them have different colors and it's
sorted by value it's easy as that and uh
then yeah and and we also um set the
title and this based on this function so
that in year so the the actual the s
year is uh on from the slider is is
being uh updated so the title is being
updated by the year selected in the
slider we have some style settings like
adding a color poet once again it's not
that interesting and then we set this is
the animation option where we uh just uh
made it so that that the chart reacts
instantaneously there's no delay and
then we call this chart show method so
that the chart is being updated all the
time when the slider changes and and
that's it so again in 50 lines of code
uh you created uh an interactive uh
animated uh chart that that makes it
easy for everyone to play around and
understand how much revenue different
music form is generated in different
years and lastly uh the drill down
example is to Showcase how the B
directionality could be used uh is like
it it shows once again the total of the
the music revenues and if you click on
any of these columns representing one
year of data then we'll zoom into that
uh year and then we drill down and show
the components of that year uh so the
music formats for the specific here side
by side and if I click on uh anywhere
else then we Zoom back to the original
View and so how we do such an how we
build such an app with with streamlet
visu is um asically there's nothing
interesting in this bit we create the
style as a separate object that we add
to the Chart later on uh and uh yeah
this one is is a specific event handler
that seems to not run this time but so
it's not that important um we set the
tool tip to true this tool tip is what's
being shown on the chart elements if you
move your mouse over so basically uh I
think there's like one specific bit
here
um yeah so we we set the rerun on click
to true
uh meaning that whenever you click on
the chart it's something Zachary added
there then the the the chart is being
the the yeah it's being reanimated and
uh so basically what we do here is that
there is uh a bar clicked um value that
we get from with this chart get uh
method where uh we read basically uh the
year uh from the the marker that's being
clicked the year value and uh what you
do here is that if bar clicked is not so
if there is no bar that is being clicked
then we build this chart that you can
see here and if a bar is clicked then we
apply the filter so that the record year
equals to the bar clicked and uh and I
also added this bit where the record
Revenue should not be zero otherwise
just like with the with the slider app
we would also have uh we would also show
music formats that for that specific
year uh equals to zero like in 19997
download streaming a DVD and uh right so
in the drill down bid it's a little more
advanced that you only see uh the values
uh so the music formats for which the
value is greater than zero so it it
looks better and so what you need to see
here is that in the else part uh the
chart animate method is actually called
twice so first it just zooms into that
specific bar and then in the second bit
uh it creates the the this grouped uh
version the group column where we show
the components and if I click anywhere
else then this part is being prerun so
that U that uh uh you know we we see all
the data and the data filter is is
emptied out and that's about it so um
these are some easy examples to to get
started with when you want to understand
how visu works that's for the Builder to
use for and then how to implement it
with the stream L that's the intro to
Vis stream L app is for you can
obviously find the code uh in on GitHub
I I think you should have the GitHub
link also for yourself if if you see it
but Zachary might correct me on that
might be because I'm one of the U um
creators of this
app okay uh back to you
Zachary okay um there's a few different
questions that have been asked in the
chat so keep asking those I think I've
answered the ones that are on there um
but uh yeah check out the chat and
and use the Q&A function um as well but
yes that what what Peter said was
correct um for any any app um on
community Cloud that were that's based
on a public repo as this one is you
should be able to click on that little
GitHub
button um to see it um so I want to show
you today um we really want you to get
you know get started and get your hands
dirty so we tried to make a good way to
do that and so what you have here um is
uh p-g global. stream.app it's a very
exciting it's a very exciting app um you
see it's got two pages here um one of
them is uh has a very exciting toggle on
it and the other is and I think Peter
mentioned this and you saw an example of
this but one of them is also has this
this racing bar chart Style um and and
and the reason specifically created this
um was not to
um is not really to show off those
particular things I think the intro vizu
is is a you know shows kind of some more
advanced ways that you can use these
things but this is meant to be a kind of
a template app for you to get started
today um so instead of looking
at
um instead of looking at the app itself
let me let me click here and look at the
code um actually let me see if I can
switch the URL and keep sharing it all
right there we go it opened a new tab
but okay so so this is the stream Vis
data Global repo and if you look in the
if you look in here what you'll see is
there's uh one python file in the top
level folder um a bunch of
csvs um of some sample data and then a
Pages uh a Pages folder that has has the
racing. um the
um uh most important thing I want to
show you today is the read me so um we
want to make we want to give you the
opportunity
to to try this out to to try this out to
play with it to make your own um to make
your own visu app today during this
tutorial and
so
apologize
um uh one of the things that that
streamlet Community cloud has recently
uh enabled is that you can actually take
an app and you can Fork an app um using
GitHub code spaces so that without
installing any anything locally you can
work um you can make make a version of
your app have the editor in the browser
and just play with it there and then you
can go and and and share it from there
um there are going to be two
requirements and I I I forgot to add
these to the read me but the two
things the two things you'll have to do
is you will need a GitHub um a GitHub
account hopefully many of you have one
of those already if not um it's pretty
pretty easy and straightforward to
create one and you'll also need to
create an account at share. stream.io
which again is is is pretty easy and you
just link to your link you can create it
using your GitHub account um so if you
don't have those you will need those to
actually get
started um once you've done that um this
shows you step by step what you can do
to make your own um streamlet vizu app
um and actually we're we're going to um
hopefully have some time at the end to
to to show off some of the things that
you've made so if you click this button
here open and GitHub code spaces it will
open up and and it'll give you the
opportunity to create a fork of of this
app you can call it what you can um you
can change the repo name if you uh no
actually maybe you can't but you can
change the url if you want um it gives
you some gobble tog URL or just leave it
as is but this URL will be live and
sharable at at after you've built this
and you can share share your work that
way
so if you hit the hit the fork button it
does take a little bit of time um to
spin up to create it'll Fork the REO
copy all the code um so you'll have
you'll have all these csvs you'll have
all the python files um and it will also
create a codespace so codespace is just
it's
a um for all intends and purposes it's
Visual Studio code running in your
browser um where you don't have to
install anything it'll install in this
case what I have in my requirements.txt
file which if you look at it's not not
terribly exciting it just has one line
that says install streamlet vizu so
it'll install those things and you
create new codes space and um after a
minute or two you should see something
like this so you'll actually see an
editor on the left um and actually it
it'll open to the readme by default but
you can also look at the stream app.py
and it does take them it does take a few
seconds so once it pops up you'll
probably just see the editor and then a
few seconds later um maybe 30 seconds or
a minute it it'll open up in the the
editor a
browser so you get this side by-side
view of the code on the left and the app
on the right and so this is a pretty
cool thing you don't install anything
locally and you get you have this this
to work with if you want to work locally
that's great you can clone the repo work
locally um you can do that as well but
we just wanted to make it we wanted to
make it easy
um we wanted to make it easy to to do it
without doing any of that so um the
other thing The Next Step we're going to
have you do is go back to that builder
app so you you saw the link um Peter
showed you how that's
used so in this in this repo there's a
bunch of different um there's a bunch of
different csvs here's the one that is
used um in uh that's the sample data by
default if you
so if you just want to use this um but
there's also ones about about music
sales and there's ones about superhero
powers and and uh curse wordss and
tartino movies and world population
stuff um so you can you can pick one of
those that looks
interesting go to the app so download
download CSV upload it there in the app
and then choose which which columns you
want to treat as the categories and
which ones you want to treat as values
remember that you have to pick at least
one of each and then hit the update
charts button and just like Peter showed
you earlier you'll see a whole bunch of
different charts and so you'll see a
bunch of different charts and if you
like a particular one you can go to that
one and then
choose you can click on this little
expander that says show code and then
click on this button this little hover
thing that appears to copy the code and
you can um then go back to your code
spaces and create a new file so so this
is an editor on the left side of the
editor there's a there you can click on
the pages folder and click new file and
you can just call that my chart. py
you'll notice um sometimes you'll see
this with stream apps where you'll have
pages that have a number in front in
fact we've changed this one to have a
number in front the the only reason for
the number at the beginning of so in
this case uh I think it's called you
know
02 racing. py that's optional but it's
just a way to to specifically order them
in a certain order and it won't show up
in the LI it won't show up in the name
here it'll just say in this case my
chart
um uh one of the things to that's you
might um might catch you up is is when
you change the code on the left you
won't necessarily see it updated right
away on the right you actually need to
hit the R button has something to do
with the way code spaces doesn't
actually save the files or something I'm
not really sure but but should be pretty
straightforward if you just hit the if
you if you click in the browser again on
the right and hit the R button that'll
tell stream that hey this is you know
reload the latest code um so you should
see this pretty quickly pop up a my
chart file and here you have the exact
chart that you copied and created from
the Builder app and it's now in
your it's now in your um now in your app
um and I wanted to show you let me let
me look let me show you give you an
example specifically of one way this can
be used so so this is the this is the
main page that you'll see if you go to
you know Piata global. stream.app this
is the code behind that and essentially
this is just the card the code that you
would get from the Builder app so this
this chart. animate and um and it does a
filtering in this case it doesn't filter
it at all it does some config and some
styling a lot of this is is optional you
could do this a bit a bit simpler but
um the the the dynamic part really comes
down here so this is a this is a pattern
I often use for these and that's one of
the reasons why I gave you this is um
you'll you'll do the initial animate to
set up kind of the default chart that
you want to show people and then if you
have widgets like in this case we have a
a toggle so remember that in streamlet
um widget W uh widgets just give you a
variable and that variable is whatever
the widget is so this is sd. toggle it's
that little neat um Left Right toggle
button like a checkbox but it looks a
little nicer for something like this and
if the toggle is turned on then this
Branch will so it'll sort by value and
this it'll sort by none and just
uh
um
uh just do that real quick again um just
to make it clear what's going on there
that's what that's what causes this so
the second the first animate sets up
this basic chart and then the second
animate it either filters by or orders
by the total or or it orders by nothing
so essentially
um going back to the code
um
um essentially it will it will
um either do
nothing if you do this or it will order
by value so that's really the way you
can you can have a streamlet widget and
interact with it um and have
it uh
sorry all right and and last thing I
want to show you which this this it says
to do this in the read me but just to
make it explicit essentially this is the
same code except you've added a year
slider so this return this in this case
there's only three years of data so it's
not super exciting but and then we call
it data.
filter and one of the things that you'll
notice is that um and there's a few
different fancy uh options being passed
here um but you can pass it multiple
objects so like config a config in this
case which changes the Sorting you can
also pass a filter that filters the data
this is kind of the syntax of filter in
the data and then at the end I do that
show these other arguments are really
optional um but they help they help show
some of the some of the more advanced
things um so this link is in the I can
post it in the chat again but this is
really we actually want you to we want
you to do this we want we want you to
get started um and try it out today so
let me pass it uh pass it back to Peter
if he wants to say anything yeah I mean
um great the I I I love uh how
straightforward this thing can be I
really hope uh you can make good use of
it folks um and uh I think we it's it's
so like for the REM remaining part of uh
of the session uh we would like you to
try it out like what we build for you
and try and build your first uh first
streamlet app with iPad visu chart in it
I actually added a couple of links uh in
the resources page that that that should
be suitable but if there's something
missing Zachary just uh please add that
too and um yeah so but there's the min
oh yeah the Builder repo I guess that
that would also be necessary uh to get
started and uh so we had a discussion
with with Jim and and prant because uh
obviously we haven't uh used the this
air meet before and we didn't know what
to expect with the arrangement of the
the virtual tutorial in a way that you
can you know do work independently but
still reach out for for our our support
and we figured uh we will create
breakout rooms um 11 of them to be more
specific so there'll be six people in
each room and U if anybody needs help so
you you'll be assigned to these room
rooms randomly and uh you can work there
with with five uh fellow uh participants
and you can obviously ping each other
for uh for some support but you can also
just come here to the main session and
and leave a uh like a request for
support uh in the chat we we don't
really know how this works but we will
hope to get to you uh soon enough and so
we still have more than 30 minutes left
from the session and we hope that you
know we will have a a joint Q&A uh
session towards the very end where we
would be uh delighted to see some of you
showing us uh your first uh interactive
stream L apps that you built uh using uh
you know everything that we prepped for
you uh so I think uh yeah we you might
want to take like a one minute break and
and sip some water or visit the toilet
or something because now comes the part
where you we we stop talking and and you
get to to do the the the work on your
own and it seems like Jim wants to add
something work nope I'm just saying let
me know and I'll hit the breakout
rooms yeah I mean uh is there any
questions or comments about everything
that's being shared so far uh that we
should address uh together or discuss uh
as a group uh I don't see any new uh
comments or questions in the Q&A session
or in the chat window but uh feel free
to to to yeah ask anything you want from
us
or yeah I'll just give you a
minute and uh I'll also start uh to
campaign for you to
[Music]
um to give us uh uh your opinion so I'll
if if you have like one minute or two
that you want to spend with something
else or you're done with uh
experimenting with the uh the app
building part and you just want to wait
for the joint uh Q&A there's a bitly
link that that will redirect you to a
Google feedback form it would take two
three minutes of your time to feel as an
early stage startup with open source
tools it's it's crucially important for
us to understand uh what you think about
what we do and to get your feedback so
and you can also sign up for a quick
interview with me or somebody El from
our team and also we me and Zachary we
would want to learn how to improve uh
what we did today so that would be
awesome if you could spend a couple of
minutes uh it's kind of like the way to
to um appreciate our efforts here uh but
first things first you you should be try
and build if you want uh an app streamly
app with ipu chart in it uh so I think
yeah let's get started with the with the
breakout room bit and and see how it
goes
okay thank you
Jim
all right so this is our
room looks like there's no everybody
else is
gone yeah you should be able to see on
the right side I think if you click on
the breakout room IC breakout rooms yeah
see who's in which
room and then
okay
okay sorry Zachary I don't hear that
sorry I just said it I was looking at
the I was looking at the people in
session and it looks like people are
back in the looks like it worked yeah
yeah okay so welcome back to the main
session everybody thanks uh I mean we
we'd love to hear uh some success
stories or you know if if you had any
chance to to actually build something uh
we might even be able to give you the
floor to to show it or if you have any
questions this might be the best time to
to edit either in the Q&A part or or in
the uh the chat bit we still have like
eight minutes from this session uh I I
will keep pursuing uh you to uh feed
fill out the feedback form either in the
next eight minutes or maybe after the
session because that's uh really
valuable for us to to understand uh what
you thought about everything that
happened here and then and yeah our tool
and and what you what you would actually
want to do with it but yeah so I I'll
just shut up for a bit and and let you
do the talking or just share any
questions or comments you might
have
how does the sample app decide on the
aggregation function looks like it's
using a sum but how could that be
changed yeah so uh this is the
aggregation Logic the sum is the
aggregation logic uh by default but uh I
mean let me really quickly try and find
the the part in our documentation site
that shows you how you can change that
and uh I'll give the floor so if you
have any other questions just add it
there and I'll come back with a link uh
to that specific uh
feature what one thing that's helpful is
you can actually use the Builder app to
figure that out so let me show um this
so this is uh what the Builder app um I
I clicked sample data and I just picked
a couple columns and if I look here to
see the code um it's a little verbose
because as Peter mentioned it's setting
a bunch of things that are kind of
default um but if I if I change this to
to mean I hit update charts you'll see
them update
and
uh so here you see where it does mean uh
item sold um and if I change it to min
um there you can see this changes to Min
item sold so it's in the config when you
set the Y
um um you can you can change it uh that
way in this in this dictionary so this
that's a helpful thing this is a helpful
thing for even for also learning the
learning the syntax um uh and Zachary
you're brilliant even better with
teaching visu syntax than myself so
thanks but I I I added the the one that
one chapter from the
tutorial of ipai visu that talks about
this thing specifically but yeah we we
try to cram everything inside the
Builder app that could come useful such
as sorting and changing the aggregation
logic and and whatnot so yeah but that
was a great question Brandon thanks a
lot for for for adding that and if
anybody has any other questions we still
have some
time did anybody manage to build some
anything interesting they'd like to
show I know it wasn't a ton of time to
get
started is there a way to sort the
superheroes by
height great question how do I leverage
specs between graphs like say colors I
just changed bars to red but into files
okay so let's start let's try and go one
by one so superheroes by height uh let
me I mean it guess it's the heroes
information CSV so we have height there
yeah so you just need to add height uh
to uh your chart and then sort by value
it's actually also in the Builder app uh
so Zachary you can if if you want to to
show it uh because I I don't have it
right does it have
height yeah it it should the superheroes
information uh sorry the heroes
information CSV should have hi but only
there's like one toggle for sorting by
value uh in the Builder app that that
switches this on uh if if you want to
but but also I guess in the sample apps
there are ton of it's just you need to
have that value on the chart U and then
it will sort uh the the markers
based on that if you have two values and
you create a scatter plot or something
then that doesn't make any sense so it
won't work anymore and how do I leverage
specs between graphs like say colors um
so you changed bars to Red
Brian how you added uh some category to
the color Channel or I'm not sure how
you did it but if you actually if you
did that say like adding a category like
in the superhero B for example uh gender
uh which is a
category uh to the uh um to the color
Channel then you just need to add the
same category on each of these charts
each of these graphs to the color
Channel and they will have the same
color so that's the only thing you need
to uh keep an eye out for to to have the
same category or the same categories in
the same
order uh what are technical
considerations re required to integrate
IP for own cloud visualization report
capabilities such as Asia okay I I guess
this is a time where I just
uh come out as a non technical person so
uh the honest answer is I don't know uh
but uh Zachary but I mean this is this
is the link to our slack workspace and
if you join there there'll be my our
Tech Team ready to help you but Zachary
might have a thing or two to say ah
okay MH I'll come back to Brian but re
answer this question first the so in
terms of um in terms of integrating it
into there you know there's a couple you
know for example you've seen it used in
Jupiter notebooks you've seen it used in
streamlet apps those are the two that
I'm most familiar with if you have those
and are running the and are you
certainly can run those in inside of
azure so that we do have we have people
who who who run and host their own
stream apps for example inside of azure
or host their own you have have some
kind of Jupiter um hosting uh tool and
so I beyond that um I mean it is a
JavaScript library so if you wanted to
use the JavaScript library under the
hood you could just host it the way you
host um any any sort of web app on your
um so yeah it depends depends what what
you have
available um so Peter and Zachary
there's only one minute left uh we can
close the session the chat will yeah
yeah let's wrap it up yeah yes so you
can stay in uh chat with the tiendes but
the recording is going to stop thank you
so much for the session okay yeah it was
very informative thanks very much
everyone for joining in thank you thank
you and uh I hope you had a great time
again uh please fill out the followup
the feedback form and just join the
slack and then we'll be both of us will
be there to to follow up with the
conversation and thank you for taking
yeah taking through the 90 minutes uh
all of you it was a it was a great
pleasure to to to do this thank you all
Zary would you want to
add no yeah thank you
all okay